first on CBS this morning we're getting
a look at potentially groundbreaking
technology that could one day change the
future food safety scientists at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
are using artificial intelligence to
create a system that will allow people
to test foods and drinks for
contamination every year an estimated
one in six Americans get sick from
contaminated foods and 3,000 people
actually die from this
Niki batiste got a behind-the-scenes
look at how the new technology will work
she's at a food market right here in
good old New York City I like the look
of this grocery store Nikki good morning
to you it's colorful gala good morning
well if you've ever gotten sick from
eating bad produce or question that
expiration date on your groceries there
may be a solution MIT is developing new
technology that will give consumers
control when it comes to avoiding
dangerous foodborne illnesses no lettuce
no a lot of water there's bread in 2015
Allie Goldman contracted a
life-threatening case of e.coli and
spent more than a month in a coma when I
woke up I was really unaware of where I
was they had carried me to a mirror
because I couldn't walk and I looked in
the Mary didn't know who I was it was
about 95 97 pounds Goldman got the
bacteria after eating a spinach salad
sandwich at a New York cafe she hasn't
eaten lettuce in nearly four years how's
your relationship with food now I dread
it I live in constant fear every single
day but a team of scientists at the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
could soon change that will this
technology be able to read ecoli and
lettuce I hope so lead in water I hope
so fake alcohol on my vacation
definitely faunal Adeeb is leading the
team if we do it ourselves when we first
arrived at MIT they had worked through
the night to show us this the early
stages of a system they say could
revolutionize food safety we hope to be
able to build a portable device that a
person can take with them when they're
trying to buy something from a
supermarket or from a farmers market a
deep envisions the device will be the
size of a phone charger and plug into
your cell phone but right now it looks
like this
a black piece of foam with green
antennae according to a Deeb the device
is pre-programmed to detect specific
contaminants in products like milk and
alcohol the device reads signals from a
wireless sticker on the food or beverage
packaging and transmits the results to a
phone app we want to test it for
contaminants the team showed us what a
prototype of the app might look like you
can see that it is actually fake alcohol
MIT believes the technology could help
people avoid safety hazards such as
tainted alcohol which either kills or
blinds hundreds of people every year the
goal is for consumers to one day be able
to use the technology to test meals in
restaurants and at home you could also
envision future smart fridges that
incorporate this technology to detect
contaminated food or food spoilage if I
scan food and I'm told that this lettuce
is contaminated where else does that
information go it would be uploaded to
an online database ideally this database
will even be connected to server as
which regulation boards have access to
regulation boards like the CDC which
says 128 thousand Americans are
hospitalized by foodborne illnesses
every year we have great technology now
and still 48 million Americans get sick
every year while consumers like Goldman
are interested in being able to detect
contamination themselves food safety
lawyer Bill Marler hopes grocery stores
will use the technology to I see the
best use of this kind of technology as
sort of before it hits the marketplace
before it goes on a grocery store shelf
in the near term I hope consumers will
do it in the long term I hope that it
will become so seamless that it will
disappear into the environment such that
it is in the infrastructure of the
grocery store do you think in the future
it will be as mainstream as paying with
your phone like we do now I certainly
hope that that this will be the case
professor at Deep told CBS News this
technology could be in people's hands
within 5 years he also hopes one day the
system will be able to detect sugar
levels and calories which biana of
course could help diabetics
and anyone watching their weight sounds
promising nicking you told us yesterday
the FDA is looking into this technology
as well thank you